كل يوم من الحرب على غزه اصبح يؤكد امرا
واحدا وهو انهيار منظومه القيم الحاكمه
للمجتمع الدولي القيم القانونيه والحضاريه
والانسانيه فمشهد الفرجه العالميه على
القتل والسحل والاباده الجماعيه للشعب
الفلسطيني في غزه على مدى اكثر من 72 يوما
لا يريك غير العجز المستحكم في مؤسسات
تواضع العالم على انها ادواته في كبح قوه
القوي الاماره بالاعتداء
والسيطره وقد استقر لدى العالم ان الامم
المتحده
ومؤسساتها هي محل هذه المسؤوليه في حفظ
الامن والسلم الدوليين وانها هي لا غيرها
المسؤوله عن صون حقوق الانسان من ان تمس
واول هذه الحقوق حياته لكن الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده التي تمثل قرار الامم
الاعضاء تتحول الى مجرد حشد بلا قوه
فقرارات يداس عليها من قبل اخرين هنا
الخمسه الكبار الدائمون في مجلس الامن
يكفي ان يقول احدهم لا فتتعطل الاراده
الدوليه عن الفعل خلال الحرب على غزه
احبطت الولايات المتحده محاولتين لوقفها
وقف الحرب الذي يعني وقف قتل الاطفال
والنساء ووقف قصف المستشفيات والمدارس وقف
تدمير البنيه التحتيه والمرافق العامه
لمليون و500 الف مواطن يعني وقف التوحش
الاسرائيلي الذي ارتد بالقوى الدوليه
المسيطره على العالم الى حاله مرضيه
تستعذب رؤيه القتل وسفك الدم الفلسطيني
على يد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليس
الفلسطيني وحده اليوم من يساله بل احرار
العالم كلهم يتساءلون ما الذي يعنيه
المجتمع الدولي وما الذي يعنيه الميثاق
العالمي لحقوق الانسان وما الذي تعنيه
العداله الدوليه وما هو تعريف الكرامه
الانسانيه بالنسبه للدول التي تزعم
ريادتها الاخلاقيه والحضاريه للعالم اين
ذهب التراث الضخم لمفاهيم حقوق الانسان
الذي ما اكثر ما وظفته الدول الكبرى ضد
الدول الصغرى تخيفها وهي تقف على اعلى
منبر تحذر وتتوعد من يجرؤ على انتهاك تلك
الحقوق حرب غزه بما وقع فيها من مجازره
ومن استباحه للكرامه الانسانيه ومن
انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان مما تبثه
شاشات التلفزه على مدار الساعه قد فضحت كل
مزاعم التحضر لدى الدول الكبرى فالحرب
بوقائع اليوميه التي مثلت مشهدا متصلا
لماسات الانسان الفلسطيني لا تشكل وثيقه
ادانه لاسرائيل
ولجيش المعتدي فحسب بل هي ادانه للوضع
الانساني الدولي كله يقول رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ان بلاده ستواصل الحرب حتى لو
تراجعت الدول عن دعمها لان غزه تشكل مهددا
وجوديا لاسرائيل وهو زعم لا تتردد
الولايات المتحده في قبوله والترويج له
لكن لا احد رغب او يرغب في رؤيه اسرائيل
بوصفها حاله كانت دائما ولا تزال مهدده
للوجود الفلسطيني عامله على محوه من وجه
الارض تخوض المقاومه في غزه حربها بيقين
راسخ ان القوه وحدها هي التي ترد الحقوق
مهما عظمت التضحيات فقد رات ما فعلت
اسرائيل بالسلطه الفلسطينيه منتج عمليه
السلام وكيف انتهت عندها حارسا امنيا تقوم
بينها وبين بين مشروع الدوله الفلسطينيه
مستوطنات من ورائها مستوطنات ووهم من
ورائه وهم تصنع غزه ملحمته في الثبات
والصبر وباخذ عدوها بباس لم يعرفه من قبل
فثم فارق نوعي في بواعث القتال وفي النظر
الى التضحيات بينها وبين عدوها فهي رابحه
في احوالها جميعا لقد فشل العالم في انصاف
الشعب الفلسطيني الذي تقاتل مقاومته اليوم
ليس نزولا عند شهوه قتل لديها ولا لان
الشعب الفلسطيني لا يحب الحياه ولكنها
تقاتل هي وشعبها من اجل القضيه انها
القضيه التي لا يريد العالم رؤيتها ولا
الحديث عنها فالمسؤولون الامريكيون
الطوافون بالمنطقه منصرف همهم الى تحرير
من تحتجزهم المقاومه في غزه غافلون عن
ماساه الملايين من الشعب الفلسطيني
وغير مترفين باصل الصراع واصل العنف الحرب
على غزه كشفت اكذوبه المجتمع الدولي
واكذوبه عدالته وفضحت مزاعم الرياده
الحضاريه والاخلاقيه للدول الكبرى
فالولايات المتحده ضال في الحرب ضلوع
اسرائيل تقول المقاومه هل تكون غزه منعطفا
في تاريخ المنطقه وربما الانسانيه كلها
ينذر بذهاب عالم ويبشر ببروز اخر اكثر
عدلا
وانسانيه واقل اجراما وقبحه ذلك ما تطلبه
مواكب الاحرار في العالم
كذلك